[Music]
you know if you're leading with hate if
you're acting out of hate it's not going
to get you anywhere it's not going to
come back around it's going to come back
around and bite you
and and i ask this respectfully man like
have you acted with hate in your life
every every time i try
every time that i constantly try even
when i wake when i was in penitentiary i
wake up and i used to say okay
i got to do this you know
so what am i reading for doing call you
that guard sometimes that's okay if i'm
doing it just for myself then that don't
check the boxes why why are you doing
this here because
if this dude keep moving the way it is
you just gonna touch him up but if you
if he keep on the way he going he's
gonna end up somebody gonna kill him so
maybe he'll learn something from this it
always had to be there or else with the
way this guy here is going he's been the
cause of a race war he finna cause a war
and we got homeboys doing illegal work
we got home boys closed to go home it's
gonna be five or six men lose they lied
behind his stupidity so
that's got to stop right now and my
reason it's always it always try to be i
don't try to go in anger which i
probably have got mad sometime in the
process but my general ideal thinking
when i think about it because i when i
go to sleep at night i always replay
everything that happened that day in my
head anything that i miss but when i
look at a situation and i feel like i
didn't address it right and i feel like
i overdid it i come back and try to make
up for it on the slide you know i ain't
gonna hang on kids stay behind but i'll
come back and let them know yeah man
i'll live rough for you
well what's going on what's what you
need here what you need that so i i i
come back on it but i always try to make
my decision on the fact that is he gonna
help him is he gonna save his life
because the way he going somebody gonna
kill him we had an incident with uh
when our own voice he he got on the door
and said
sereno
it's moreno he said some wild stuff
about him there's
serenio finna mario on tv for meredith
so
this black chick you know
and he talks so bad about the black
chick and everything going on he
i mean he was just disrespectful on the
door all these dudes all of my no psycho
gasolina all them every last one of them
dudes had you ain't gonna pretty much
get the adx let's help you let like me
but everybody else died that you didn't
kill two sellers at least or the kill
once you get to what to get to super max
yeah yeah yeah so you ain't just you
know it you don't just get there babe
baby fade where he had to kill three
but
these dudes here all of them had bodies
in prison and these dudes come out and
they lined up they lined up they ready
you know bam we ain't trying to
disrespect listen man i said i
understand y'all we got this here ain't
going on then we dealt with the dude but
we dealt with him not to death but to
teach him a lesson and i do god be my
witness i seen that dude two years later
man he said man i didn't know i didn't
know that was that was them dudes and he
called out tonight he said yeah i've
been hearing about them dude man
i i didn't know they were there when i
was saying he said man i thank you bam
man i see man i'm trying to go home man
i ain't got he's a man
and i said i said yeah man i said that's
really that's basically the reason why i
did that man because you sitting there
you're putting yourself in a situation
them dudes ain't got nothing to lose man
you just saying something that sounds
slick on the dope and being
disrespectful toward them dudes that
they race and that ain't cool at all you
know and so sometimes you
you have to do it for the person on good
or for the environment on good
you know what i'm saying but
i i tried not to like i said i tried not
to let hate be the leading factor you
know i'm only human though so yeah yeah
yeah
remember i tell you what the the
preacher dude tell me yourself why you
care so much about the
about the guys who out there doing
knowledge you
and my question to him but why don't you
care enough about him that's that's the
question you know i'm saying yo you're a
pastor man how how can you not have love
in your heart these cheer you know what
i'm saying these somebody children are
going on they're making they're making
mistakes and going on they're going on
and unfortunately people some people die
for it and the best thing we need to do
is get to them people and talk to them
kids man and and cost their millions and
they ain't dumbest we have to show them
where it's not it's beneficial to you
not to hound this situation this way you
know i'm saying look at what i don't
lost i lost 27 years of my life when i
come out here i'm the dumbest dude in
the room now everything didn't change
that's not a cool way to be
everything every everywhere i go where
the bottom used to be which bottom is
ideology now in our hearts and in all
over the world but still when i go to
places i used to hang out at ain't
nothing but but but grass and weeds
so time don't stand still for it don't
go in jail and think you're gonna come
back out and then time's gonna stand
still and you're gonna pick up where you
left out because it don't exist like
that
my record in penitentiary
does not show you no model inmate
i fought against things that i thought
was wrong
i stood up against things i got gas and
going on if they put me in a situation
wrong i fought and i stood on it and i
come out here and do the same thing so i
wouldn't i'm they didn't broke me to the
point that i'm coming out here and
saying what i'm saying
i'm saying what i'm saying because it
makes sense and i and i don't want to
see these children instead of be taking
lives and look at what they're not
taking the life they ain't doing nothing
exchanging their life because this
person died and you go to jail the rest
of your life you ain't took nothing you
ain't walking away clean free
when a person is committed to what he
doing that's right unbeaten whether it's
murder or what is this and that there
he's gonna be good at it he's gonna put
his heart into being good at it so if
you can find something else for him to
put his heart into he gonna be good at
that too some of these guys who who i
was around who were good friend of mine
not trusting with my life got 33 bodies
and going on like that but the mindset
now
is they don't they if they had to do
over again they'll do different and they
also want to help the children to make
different decisions going on they can't
take back what they did and going on but
yet still they would they would change
that and that that's that's the thing
about a place like that i've been there
i don't see any dudes coming there
and and themselves going to come in
there and they intelligently super
intelligent and then in two years they
eating feces off the wall covering
themselves in pieces and eating feces
off the off the wall
why do you think that they go crazy
because if the brain can't
can't reach outside and connect with
something then it's going to turn on
itself and turn inside did you see did
it i seen it did you see anything with
with yourself that way did you did you
start to go that i used to do what i
used to do is number one
i cut off everybody do my bible story
the only person i stayed in contact with
was my sister and a friend of mine named
by the kid i had helped a long time ago
stuck with me through the whole bed
but
i would i had a routine i get up watch
my cartoon
and i read my bible and i cut off the
world it's like being in a glass
sarcophagus
you can see the world but you can't
affect it in knowing fashion so you
especially you put yourself through hell
because you can see everything going on
but you can't touch
you know what i'm saying so by you
seeing this like old dude said one time
uh
if you gonna lock me up forever take my
window too cause i don't want to see
what i'm missing you seem saying that
the same thing with me i don't wanna i
can't you know if my daughter called me
and said hey just help him just help me
what i'm gonna do i'm walking around
eight by ten cell and getting mad
so so there's nothing i do so i i don't
need to hear that i don't need it
because they do never mess up my beard
and then i'm gonna be the zapdog because
now my brain gonna be trying to figure
out ways that i can help but then i'm
start following myself because you can
lie
to a lot of people but you can't lie to
yourself when you sitting in that cell
everything that you
the situation you said you said come on
man i know i i should have did that
better i didn't have to do that this way
you go through that with yourself and
you got to forgive yourself for those
things if you don't forgive yourself for
those things it'll eat you up and drive
you crazy so you have to look at the
things okay i was who i was then but i'm
gonna be somebody different now but i
should have did that better and now i
will do that about it if i get another
opportunity but you can't lie to
yourself and say well i did that because
he was feeling swaying at me and going
on because we played back and everything
you can see me i do want to finish
swinging at you you just mad and you did
that going on so you have to and if you
lie to yourself then you bring on
something i'll start playing game with
you now you ain't going to bear to bleed
nothing yeah babies believe nothing you
say and so you always keep it real with
yourself hey man you know yeah i
shouldn't have did that you know but
that's behind me now to get myself full
and let's get on and do this you know
make sure i don't do it no more and like
me when i make mistakes because i like
chocolate
and whenever they have something that i
like
if i if i do something then i punish
myself by not eating it not eating
whatever i like
like what like give me an example of
that black if they i love chocolate so
if they have chocolate cake and i didn't
curse cause you see i generally don't
use professors if i didn't cuss
the cuss and being in the conversation
because i don't i don't lie
i don't like the ogre i don't like
myself to ugly so sometimes we are
direct you know most time inside we had
to talk with sign language but out there
we're wrecked we can talk to the through
the fences over the wild so if i get in
the conversation and get heated come on
cause it takes me like three days to
come down when i get mad that's why i
don't like to get mad
so i'll come back in
and next good thing to have i take it
i'll take it out the play and smash it
up and throw it away because that's my
punishment for lied myself so that made
me think twice about doing it again
so i i i try to make it a habit of
punishing myself because i know i ain't
gonna allow nobody else to do it so i
checked myself to keep somebody else
from having to do it
and that used to kind of keep me
pretty much but i ain't didn't keep me
straight he kept me sane though
hey man
uh sean what you you you got anything
else that you want you want to talk
about man um people don't understand how
early you know i mean like this uh as
far as bam um you're talking about
13 years old you uh you robbed that
that story when he told me that i'm like
man i was 13 you know what i mean what
you know me i was playing with legos and
[ __ ] and i'm like
you know helping mama get some rent
money so
you know and i think that's a you know i
mean just to
he was just so advanced you know what i
mean like i don't i don't explain it um
but the story where he actually robbed
uh uh it was a convenience store
yeah no it was it was a regular
little corners though but
we uh i heard the man in there
talking about telling the police that
the lung if the lung go out more than
twice it just arrest chewing through
them i was getting my grandmother some
green
so i come back up there with a pot and
looked it over
and we jiggled the thing jigging it
three times police came two times then
coming in but
it's a big old drop down now so i had to
get him get a bag get to get a pillow
case and tie screen on the pillowcase
and i had to take the take the pipe and
go down the pipe and then get up get out
on the desk with the cash register and
then you get off there so i get on the
pipe so i get the screwdriver getting
the cash register and i grab all the
money but when you pop it open it's got
the money under there and some rings and
stuff i guess the dudes buying rings for
people in the neighborhood where they
was pawning what else so i grabbed all
that out and i just went on start
throwing everything in the pillowcase
there started grabbing the most
expensive look at my kid and put it in
my pillowcase then i get out of and i
went home and i get in my room my
brother come back there
like what you got there boy let me see
what you got here going on so i gave me
give him his cut and then he looked
through the
ledger
you're like
man
where'd you get this from i saw i got
that on the case man you got to take
this back that's man i'm not going to go
break back in no store and i just
already he said no dude he's man listen
it's belong to the mob man he's got too
many names in it you better take this
back
now he said i'll go with you this one's
going scared he's scared
he's scared to death
he went back with me
he went back with me and i climbed down
and said put that jimmy exactly where
you got it for and i put it back on the
k in the cash register it was
for the last yeah that's that's that's a
while too many last six months our next
sigma mother out peeping at every car
pad
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody it's jon
and bam bam the dog uh first on behalf
of both of us and everybody from the
real ones team i just want to sincerely
thank you guys for for tuning in the
folks that i bring on the show they're
family to me and uh being able to tell
their stories and bringing you into
their world is something i'm i'm just
super proud of and uh again grateful
that you guys tune in we've decided we
want to take things just a step further
we're going to introduce a patreon
community and basically what that means
is if you become part of this community
look i already board bam bam if you want
to become a part of this community
you're going to be able to hear episodes
early and all that ad free and all that
good stuff but there's all this behind
the scenes footage all this stuff that
we've shot
that really brings you into the folks
that we've had on the show really brings
you into their world you're going to be
able to do live chats with me and the
folks that i bring on the show to talk
about their world talk about the issues
that they're dealing with about their
triumphs and their tragedies just go to
patreon
real ones on this website that you see
right there right on the screen that's
right in front of you this whole idea
was um something about building bridges
and and bringing people together and
bringing folks that often don't get the
mic and giving the mic to them so the
fact that you guys tune in means the
world anyways again thank you be good to
each other out there rock and roll